how does a writer know they have written
something in their true voice
i think you you know you you know what
what
true writing is you know you know what
it is
i mean i know when i'm bullshitting how
do you know just know
i i know it actors know it even in the
middle of doing it
actors can be in the middle of a play
and at some moment they can
go oh i'm bullshitting and then
actors have techniques to get them back
grounded
they look at the other actor they
connect with their being
as opposed to acting so
you know when you're bullshitting uh now
with
writing it's not about whether you're
not being true it's about
are you writing sentences that you
wouldn't speak
that's the difference between writing in
your own voice
and writing in those other four tones
that are not
a natural voice red and sung lost world
to be
a straight talk and absence of field
those are not natural voices those are
literary
you you wouldn't write like that were it
not for the fact that we live in a
post-literate
era age i mean you read books
so you have learned from school how to
write
like a writer you you write that way all
the time you use prepositional phrases
and
and participle clauses
because it's writing you you put in
adjectives and adverbs
like you bought a stamp collecting kit
full of them and you're using them
you wouldn't do that if it weren't not
for writing
if this was a pre-literate society
everything you write would be like you
talk
because there would be no other way to
write but once you start developing
these
these techniques or styles
then you learn that in school and you
mimic that when you write and when you
want to be a writer
you throw in adjectives and adverbs and
fancy verbs
you don't say he said you say he
responded
when was the last time you were talking
to someone and saying
yeah and i came home and i asked my
brother what he was doing and he
responded by saying but no you never do
that
you say i said you know where did you go
last night and he said
well i stayed out and i said the whole
night and he said yeah the whole night
and i said
you know you're going to get in trouble
with mom and dad and he said that's how
we talk
we don't go he responded and then i
murmured and then i averred
and then i retorted you you learned that
in school
you wouldn't write that way unless you
learned it
in school from writing so
you attune yourself to the difference
between
writing like you talk and writing in a
literary way
just like a a musician
knows when they hit a flat or sharp note
they hear it so if i'm
okay i'm sorry you can hear it
if i'm writing and i know that
not that it's garbage but it's it's not
true it's not authentic it's bs
as to what you said earlier okay could
you
what do you mean by true well that's
what i'm trying to determine
well but authentic writing and something
being true are two different things
i can lie but i can do it in an
authentic
voice how is that we do it all the time
we make up stories we lie well all of a
sudden we lie we start doing it like a
writer
if we did that everybody would know
we're lying
sometimes we lie better than when we
look the truth is just
the facts saying the truth
like you talk is the issue lying
like you talk is the issue
ask me to make something up okay um
let's suppose you're an attorney and
you're presenting your client's case
and maybe you know your client's guilty
but
this is your job to defend the person
the persons uh maybe involved in a ponzi
scheme
and maybe they had kids to support and
their back was against the wall and they
had to do what they had to do
and it's your duty to defend this person
and which one of those sentences you
just said
are not like you talk
it's your duty to defend this person i
don't think i would say that
you wouldn't say what it's your duty to
defend this person
you wouldn't say that i don't think so
you just said it
right but i don't think i would say it
in my real voice that is you
that's your sentence okay you're not
talking like a writer
you're talking like a person a poison
okay
you're writing like a joke
okay so then help me out here so because
we're we're doing like a little bit of a
a yeah okay okay so
so then is that my authentic voice
you can't talk like a writer
you don't know how to do that but you
know how to write
like a writer because they're two
different things
and it's very hard for someone who
thinks
that writing fancy is how they talk to
say to them
no don't do that you wouldn't use that
adjective there you wouldn't use that
adverb there
if you were just talking then people
have to just like with acting
sometimes people are overacting and they
don't even know it oh they think they're
great
but they're overacting you can smell it
a mile away so you have to
develop what hemingway called the
detector
where you can know when you're writing
an authentic sentence
this doesn't mean it's true it could be
a lie
that's not the issue the issue is are
you writing
are you acting true look if
if i'm going to be hannibal lecter i
don't need people's flesh
but i got to act like i do so it isn't
about what the story is about
it's about my ability as an actor to
look real whether i'm talking about
eating flesh
or talking about eating a rib eye steak
i still got to be talking and
performing like what i'm doing is true
so when i write something that's a lie
i still got to write it in in my natural
voice
and if i don't i should know how to do
that
and do it on purpose but that's writing
it's very hard for people to talk
like in poetic form or it's very hard
we're not
we're not trained that way uh gore vidal
and maybe william buckley could do it
you know they could uh pontificate
the american economy such as it was
labeled
during the time of lincoln when uh
unbeknownst to both of them the forces
of
capitalism had somehow merged with
socialism
had therefore even though uh people were
not aware of it
cattle catapulized itself in such a way
that the proclivities of those who
traded in the market
have scunded with whatever kinds of um
dough we might say that they could lay
their hands on if you know what i mean
see that's william buckley nobody talks
that way
that's buckley or gore vidal they know
how to
speak like that if i'm a defense lawyer
in front of a jury
i'm going to talk naturally i'm not
going to
talk like a professor of english
but if i had to talk that unnaturally
i probably would write it and memorize
it because it wouldn't come naturally to
me
unless as a defense attorney i did it a
lot
ladies and gentlemen of the jury on a
wind-swept
night when my client unbeknownst to the
proclivities of his own heart
trampled across the snow covered lawn
of the murdered victim he didn't know
realize or even perceive
that life thread moved
stretched to the very end of its core
had somehow
in the being and nothingness of time
caused him to freeze and be unable
to pick up the axe frozen standard
held up against the light of the sun and
smash it
against the victim's head no ladies and
gentlemen of the jury
he did not have the intestinal
fortitude to advance step
by inch and step by foot into the den
of the victim's own criminal
activities see that's not how you talk
that's a lot of but it doesn't
have to be
true or a lie that's separate from how i
say it how i write it you either write
the way a person talks
or you write in a literary style
and you have to know the difference
between the two and you have to know
when to do one and when to do the other
just like a good actor sometimes knows
when to act
sometimes you have to act you're being
natural and then all of a sudden you
take a line you go
i'm going to do this like shakespeare
now have you ever seen the movie
i think it's called network do you know
do you know the scene do you know the
scene where um
it's in the newsroom he brings him into
that room uh mr beale and he tells him
that
what he's doing he can't do anymore
because he's really upsetting the whole
business structure of of television and
money and all that stuff so they go into
that room
where there's a long table and there's
those green
lights that they use in board rooms and
he brings him in and he sits him down at
one end of the
ring and then he goes to the other end
and then the lines he has is
mr beal you have tampered with the
forces of nature
okay now ed beatty made
a decision i'm gonna say this line
like you might say it in shakespeare not
the way a person would talk
now the line is written as it's written
but an actor
has to interpret it that's different
from a writer
writing something in a forced literary
way
so here's an actor who's being natural
and then suddenly he becomes very
uh shakespearean um now
i will do the scene for you uh he says
um
uh mr beal um i haven't seen do you
would you like a glass of water
uh okay i just just couple things i want
to go over with you
you walk through that mr beale
you have tampered
with the forces of nature
you see mr beale the economy is a small
thing that does that and when you tell
people to say
so he switched from talking in a natural
voice
to a kind of a shakespearean big kind of
thing well
writers can do that too they can be
writing in a natural
sentence structure and then they can
shift into something
poetic and it might only be for one
sentence
because they want to kind of give
something extra to the moment
and they know how to do that so the
acting analogy i gave
you it's an acting analogy the writing
analysis would be
speaking in a normal way and then all of
a sudden you're getting very poetic
and then writing it that way and you
have to know the difference
you know and as hemingway said you have
a built-in
detector that can tell when you're doing
it
inadvertently if you do it you want to
do it on purpose
and you want to know how to write in
that fancy style
and you want to know how to write in a
very simple way
when faultsteph and henry iv part
2 sees prince hal who's now the king
and when the king henry iv was just
the prince and he hung out with falstaff
who's a rogue and a thief and a
big buffoonish comic character
once he becomes king falstaff is so
excited he tells all his minions
now that he's king he's going to call me
into the castle
and i'm going to have a job and i'm
going to make a lot of money and
and and falsifies thinking how he's
going to be able to steal money and all
that sort of stuff
and then the scene comes where the
coronation comes and hal is walking down
you know
with the coronation and falstaff is in
the crowd and he rushes out
and he says how my boy my prince
and he was expecting hal to look at him
and say falstaff come you know the whole
thing
but hal is now king and how as
king henry iv must renounce
everything that falstaff stood for
to be a good king that's what
shakespeare was writing about
what does it take to be a good king
you've got to be a man of the people
but you also have to know how to be a
king so falsif says and falstaff is the
richest
probably the most loved character in all
of shakespeare because he's funny
and he's very human and we see how he's
full of so we love him yeah great
actors play falstaff
uh he goes prince
my boy and he opens his arms
and hal looks at him and he says
i know thee not old man
fall to thy knees presume not that i am
the thing
that i was
that is pretty powerful and except for
the the
it's writing like you talk you talk
about shakespeare
i know thee not old man
presume not i am the thing i was fall to
your knees
it's writing like you talk and
shakespeare knows how to write like you
talk
and he also knows how to write
poetically and if you
go through shakespeare's plays you can
see the differences and the changes
even with absence of field when king
lear is on the heath going mad
blow winds crack your cheeks you know he
goes crazy
some of that speech is nonsense
it makes no sense because king lear is
losing his mind
he's going crazy and
shakespeare uses a little bit of absence
of feel there
so all these techniques are used by
writers but
if you didn't know to look for them you
wouldn't notice them but if you know
what you're looking for you will notice
them
even straight talk when would you say
all of a sudden well anyway
we do that when we talk all the time
yeah yeah you know
when i was 19 my father died and
i had to come home and we had to bury
him
anyway so have you been what's going on
i mean hey
tell me a little bit of something about
your life you know i haven't seen you in
20 years
we we do that in life we can be deep and
authentic and then all of a sudden we
start talking with that jibber jab away
well to be a not to be that is a
question
whether it's just nobler in the mind to
suffer the slings and arrows of
outrageous fortune
or to take arms against your sea of
troubles and by opposing in them
to die to sleep
perchance the dream hi there's the rub
that's straight talk all right there ah
there's there's the trick
you know you start doing that and the
next thing you know you're riding your
ass
that's basically what shakespeare does
here that aye there's the rub
and why does he do it he does it because
he
knows that if you don't have changes of
tone
it gets boring
boring so to die
to sleep perchance the dream
all right there's the rub for in the
sleep of death what dreams may come when
we have shuffled off this mortal coil
must give us pause
because there's the rub and then he
starts getting deep again
and he starts getting deep again and he
does straight talk a little bit later on
when he
figures out uh uh you know how he's
going to get the king
so shakespeare does that all the time
little switches
he goes from writing like you talk to
the deep
well the the lost world voice that
fancy voice man he can do poetic stuff
like like he was born doing that and he
will go to straight talk and sometimes
even absence of field
when he's got a character who's just
spouting out nonsense for
because they're going mad or because
they are a con man
you know maybe they're a con man and
they're kind of flummoxing you with
uh jibber jabber shakespeare
does all that and he knows he's doing it
you